[Music]
in angry celeb news summoned by Captain
Underpants I never read that book when I
was younger like a boy book to me I
didn't read is it a dr. Seuss book
I think it was after our generation Oh a
woman says she's traumatized after a
fender bender with comedian Tracy Morgan
- FPT Aziz - dude this guy bought a
Bugatti and that's like a two million
dollar car dude if any Ciroc sitting and
crashes it immediately
oh that's how [ __ ] baller Tracy
Morgan dude
because of the Walmart suit any
celebrity that Walmart you twice - so he
got Walmart a big huge Walmart truck
like crashed into him and almost killed
him
he was in a coma hey Fred how much did
you get we don't know but it's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] ton I would sacrifice one of you
guys for that whoo Tracy Morgan Sam
absolutely pretty marking out a [ __ ] ton
in the settlement with Walmart yeah so
now you can buy a Bugatti and just go
wreck it and then walk away and be like
yeah no you knocking away like he's
pissed
oh he's pissed oh yeah that seems like a
million or two million dollars I'm
saying you can't oh god why can't
corporate companies [ __ ] with me for
once man I'm trying to make money if you
die now your your family gets it you
don't get to enjoy it oh yeah like I
want to be rich and then you aren't rich
but you die yeah the genie covers you in
moneybags you die dad I don't want to be
in an accident it's too much I just
gonna slip and break an arm or something
you can do it and then you can't game
ever again go to like a Quiznos and fall
I wouldn't mind drowning in a milkshake
and I get money for it but if you drop
you guys dude right now by the the
syntax that's like saying I want to get
electrocuted you put the settlement and
then passes away but then you leave
she'll attack of the money yes we're
gonna say you leave Geo like the sweet
death
I see drowning is scary though like
giant you know it's not scary because
you already dead no like drowning and
like burning alive yeah that's true
there's a process good thing you weren't
a bruja yeah oh yeah it was it might be
that's why I'm so scared that's why she
was born in Mexico
that's why she had to leave Mexico she
wasn't born in Mexico she was born and
raised in Mexico or somewhere born in
Mexico and you want it and she'll move
here because people found out she was a
bruja she's lived in America for one
year
it wasn't Tijuana's Guadalajara I
actually did live in the corner during
that one year see but it was one yeah
through the accent comes from I lived in
there too is so that one here I lived in
many cities in Mexico oh dude I probably
spend more time in Mexican restaurants
than you've actually been how many
donkeys did you have in your garage no
the coach Udo's role er
I can't do delete though I'm sure I
can't wait wait tell me about the
Bugatti tell me about the Boogaard
I want to keep talking about oh you guys
think I was born a month spot yeah
anyway so Tracy Morgan he got into this
mine minor crash uh it was involving a
61 year old woman named Jocelyn and this
happened in New York they were both
trying to make a right turn but this
woman she was in the left lane so it
seems like it would be her fault but
they're both things
it's each other's no left is always at
fault right always at least in
California it doesn't matter if you're
making a left turn there's an accident a
hundred percent your fault no so she was
in the left lane making a right turn
oh they were making a right turn Oh cuz
maybe both of them go right
oh yeah I don't know if it was a turn
lane and the police are still trying to
determine who was at fault for the ins
oh I got it dude if I crashed my car
like if me and a celebrity got into a
car accident the moment he gets out of
the car and I see it's like Brad Pitt or
something
my everything's broken even if it's Brad
Pitt you wouldn't [ __ ] a dude I will
slam my face especially her vagina holy
[ __ ]
yeah let's let my face right punching
yourself in the face like you're in a
Jim Carrey movie my everything is broken
alright yeah yeah shut up you all will
benefit from this if I get the money for
that court case thank you a witness saw
like the moment like they started
recording the moment after the impact
and you could see it Tracy Morgan
getting out and being very upset
oh she was making a right turn with him
yeah he's on the right he's in the right
lane though so that means she probably
bumped into him what if he turns too
wide that could be it too I don't know
if her lane was also attorney it doesn't
look like damn that was aggressive his
[ __ ] yeah yelling like I just bought it
I just bought this car for her
traumatized I know my Bugatti I know
it's tough to feel bad it looks like
it's her fault
yeah but she's traumatized at him like
how he treated her or just like the
whole crash both oh yeah like she's just
commenting on the whole incident that
she's traumatized well I mean I get it -
even if I bought like a Nissan Sentra
and its brand new 15 minutes ago it
doesn't matter what car you just bought
that actually happened with my Honda
Civic but it wasn't within the same day
as within the same week like I think two
days later something's wrong cloud9
do when you're pulling off the look you
probably use ik bumping oh yeah he
realize he hit me and like he cuz it was
his big old truck and then I was just I
had to like follow him in the freeway
because it was the on-ramp to freeway
and I was like honking my cart like pull
the [ __ ] off her you just [ __ ] up my
door they didn't even know yeah he
didn't know luckily you worked at a body
shop so here you fix it oh that's cool
well did that on purpose to get to know
you that's all her in case you met miss
Schneider would a crash damaged isn't
that bad but then proved Bugattis on
pretty 15 minutes after buying it so
that's not like a fifty thousand dollar
pages Oh exactly
you know how much as it is just to get a
damn oil change on a Bugatti
let me guess 15 geez 7,000 and oil
change anything to want to fix that [ __ ]
- then don't buy nice cars I'm having
closer you're not even close Winnie
you're closer what twenty
5,000 for a typical oil change but it
changes always it made out of baby
Tierney thousand dollars to change its
higher I'm poor only the smartest of
baby tears - damn we reported the
insurance is upwards of four thousand a
month
I'm pores Wow just like the accessory
payments are [ __ ] crazy
I wonder if you have it leaves the the
dealership does all that for you I know
at least one of these guys right yeah
you probably can because a lot of these
like super light so there's like super
cars and then there's what are they call
like not lubricants or like hyper cars
or whatever but those those guys you
have to be on a waiting list hmm and you
usually have to have own another car in
that brand so it's like an upgrade yeah
it's like you got to get the c-class
before you get the top class yeah
there's a bunch of Ferraris and
Lamborghinis other dude that's what I'm
say I swear there's some cars that are
only made for Saudi princes debar yeah
like who the [ __ ] else can even get or
Tracy Morgan yo check it now it was very
very very his clothes look like it's two
dollars yeah well yeah he wore that to
the dealership
he's a Jesus shades Apollo clothes
$4,000 insurance 40,000 to change your
tire that's but your windshield wiper
blades like seven GS
tires are like how much for a car wash
six thousand like the way I look me
neither
stupid yeah it's gonna be about it it
goes 0 to 60 in 2.6 seconds
so does a [ __ ] Tesla X I can wait six
more seconds to go to 60 save a [ __ ] ton
of money a month the gay
give me a break with this [ __ ] it
reaches top speed of 255 it's just
bragging rights cuz who is he really
gonna race do that in Saudi Arabia in
the desert you can that Baba New York
most about car commercials how they keep
selling you the speed but I'm like you
can't even drive that fast
yeah you don't realize illegally you can
like sure you can
like why would you want to risk your
life because it's fun to kind of die
almost because it is I guess I can
understand that a little bit you like
speed I like speed and guided well you
like speed only in skywriting
so not in car all rights I heard you
drive like a gangsta bead in car right
but like I told ya like if it was on a
race track or something yeah I might
even like a hundred and fifty that's
[ __ ] crazy but it doesn't feel that
fast
there's a limit for me and then I
started it's not even that fast you go
100 miles per hour in like a shitty car
it feels faster than I'm not shaking
yeah I have gone gone 100 in a sports
car then an empty way like at 3:00 in
the morning alright 100 miles per hour
in a Camry that should scare us [ __ ] you
hit one you hit one puppy the cars like
floating far to center those race events
and those cars like the ones aren't
built for it doesn't feel like it at all
and then just then we came up behind
another car and I thought I was gonna
die but those things stop on a dime it's
crazy that's like an airplane you're
going 500 miles per hour and you don't
feel like you're going anywhere
yeah it just feels like you're an
elevator my uncle out of Dodge Viper and
it got so hot on the sides of the car
that when you're getting out if you
weren't shorts like burn the back of
your legs and he's like isn't this sick
and I'm like no this car sucks yeah it's
crazy
what was your first car Geo Prizm a
Volvo station wagon Nissan 200sx hardest
Asian white Mazda Protege oh I had a
9800 cord
I had an 87 oh damn dude look at who his
mom worked at Wells Fargo in his first
car was a [ __ ] Aston Martin Vanquish
that's not a big deal your corporate
maybe like a VP like she was like oh
that's not a big thing because here in
the SUV a little Chinese kids roll up
with like [ __ ] m3s in high school
dude it makes me want to kill no m3
Aston Martin Vanquish bra but then like
yours [ __ ] 15 year old with an m5 in
the parking lot that's stupid but still
did your first car is a [ __ ] that's a
supercar that is pretty crazy that guy's
gonna have to be on like pills and stuff
my three years where do you go from
there yeah you there's no excitement
yeah you could tell he's really loved
you knew that's good yeah
I didn't want to know I knew I knew him
through a friend and that was my dream
car and he's like you want to test-drive
it I'm like I'll [ __ ] drive one when
I [ __ ] earn it Oh what you can't even
use one no [ __ ] no you're probably one
of my moderator is one of my moderators
in my chat he's like he's at a friend's
with like all the Taiwanese rich kids
whatever and some kid he's got like a
[ __ ] private jet and like had it
named after himself
yeah my niece went to high school with
classmates that we're talking about what
type of private jet that their parents
were gonna buy Wow they're like I really
were thinking about this one but that
this one
Gulfstream six so the Gulfstream seven
God you can kill so many hookers and
those things oh yeah dude that's true
you have sex with them and then you
throw them all to people do the colors
they hunt hunkers the honkers yeah so if
there's an Instagram girl missing you
know what happened we're probably pretty
close to the truth right now it feels
weird we're gonna get killed someone's
gonna find us in killers